The Florida reef tract is the US's
only barrier-reef system.
It's about 300 miles long,
and what we saw over the last few decades
is an incredible decline in coral cover.
What we're looking at
is the potential loss
of an entire ecosystem,
which we've never
experienced in human history,
and I don't think anyone wants to find out
what that would mean if
we had a complete collapse
of our coral-reef ecosystems.
My name is Jessica Levy,
and I am the director
of restoration strategy
for the Coral Restoration Foundation.
The Coral Restoration
Foundation is a not-for-profit
headquartered in the Florida Keys.
So, here we are in one of
Coral Restoration Foundation’s
offshore coral nurseries.
It's about an acre and a half wide.
It's the largest offshore
coral nursery in the world.
And it's a spectacular site to visit.
The restoration process starts,
in the very original sense,
with collections of natural corals.
These are corals that are
at risk to some event,
so we actually go out to our local reefs
and harvest from them,
and instead of return visits to the wild,
we use that coral in a nursery system
where that original collection is allowed
to grow over time. And as it grows,
you take subsequent cuttings
from that original collection
and you produce more and more corals.
The main structure that
CRF uses and pioneered
is what's known as the coral tree.
It's a very simple structure
that floats in the water column.
It's made of PVC and fiberglass.
In our nurseries in particular,
we have upwards of 500 of
these coral structures,
and the corals are actually suspended
on those structures themselves.
So you'll see our divers swimming
through this forest of coral trees.
Some of the main activities
that they're likely to do in a nursery
is cleaning, removing algae and biofouls
and any other organisms that
have grown on those structures
and might compete with that
coral for living space.
We use very simple materials
to work on our trees.
We use wire brushes or a chisel
to clean the structures themselves.
We use clippers to actually cut the coral
or cut the monofilament line
that the coral is suspended
from the tree with.
While you can work pretty heavy-handed
with the trees themselves,
corals are a living animal,
it's a very thin layer of animal tissue,
so we're very gentle
when we're working with the coral itself.
Typically, when we
suspend a coral fragment,
it's maybe a couple of
centimeters long or wide,
and then after about nine months,
it'll grow to about
the size of a football,
at which point that is
an appropriate size,
what we call reef-ready,
and able to be moved to a
nearby restoration site.
We will go to a structure,
go to a coral tree,
and clip from those
individual corals there.
This takes advantage of a process
known as asexual fragmentation,
essentially making clones of
your original, your individual.
And we fragment from
the corals on the trees.
We'll move them to either new trees
and resuspend them to continue to grow
and take advantage of that nursery phase,
or we'll fragment from the existing stock
and go through a process of harvesting.
So we'll go to these trees themselves,
and we'll actually collect
corals from those nurseries.
Those corals are then
moved onto our boats,
and they sit in seawater,
and then they'll be transported
to a nearby restoration site
to begin the process of outplanting.
Once we're at an outplant site,
our divers enter the water.
Someone from the boat hands
them crates of corals.
Those divers then swim down.
Once we're at the reef, the
first step in the process
is to find your outplant site.
So this is an area that's
relatively hard bottom,
open, lots of space, and
available substrate to work with.
A diver then clears the reef area
where that coral is going
to eventually be secured.
What we look for is white, crisp rock.
It's basically limestone or old coral.
We then mix our two-part epoxy
in this almost, like, pulling-taffy motion
until it's one single clay or putty.
We'll take a small pinch of that epoxy
that we've just mixed,
push that into the reef substrate itself,
and then gently place the coral
on top of that point that we've cleared.
And that epoxy will harden
and have attached that
coral to the reef itself.
We'll then pretty much
step and repeat the process
until an individual diver
has gotten 100 corals down
or until a team of divers
has gotten anywhere
from 300 to 800 corals
done in a single day.
These corals are placed in clusters
of about 50 to 70 individuals.
They're placed in clusters
of the same genetic material,
so they're essentially
clones of their neighbors.
Over time, these corals
start to branch out
and they start to touch their neighbors,
and they start to fuse,
and what happens is they
create this one large thicket.
So this thicket has all these in and outs
that allow small fish to duck
in and hide from predators.
It allows for a lot of invertebrates
to thrive there as well.
This is the structure that
we really want to produce.
The important part is promoting
that genetic diversity on the reef site.
Our nursery program on an annual basis
produces probably about
40,000 reef-ready corals.
The reality is, is restoration
is never a one-off.
It's not something you do
and then pretty much ever walk away from.
There probably will always be work to do,
and the reason is, is it's
because we have not removed
all the pressures and the stress
that our reefs face today.
And until we fully remove
all these pressures,
we're still going to have
the need for restoration.
Restoration right now kind of works
to keep pace with that loss,
to keep pace with an
ecosystem still kind of going,
even if it's maybe considered
to be treading water.
It's still about keeping
the system alive,
because if we don't do anything now,
there's not going to be
anything left to work with.
This is not just a Florida problem.
Reefs around the world are facing
the exact same challenges
and scale of decline.
In the last 30 years,
global coral reefs have declined by 50%.
This has a cascading effect
on a lot of different aspects.
For example, 25% of marine life
depends on a coral-reef system
at some point in their life history,
whether they live there full-time
or they migrate to it some
point in their life cycle.
Additionally, coral reefs are a part of
a healthy ocean system.
About 70% of the oxygen
that we as humans breathe
comes from our oceans.
Florida, in particular,
sits at about 98% decline,
which means about 2% coral cover left,
which, although drastic and terrible,
it's better than zero.
We don't want to find out
what happens when we hit zero.
It's easy to talk about the impact
of a degraded coral reef
to a local community
that has a very one-to-one connection.
The reality is it affects all of us,
whether you live on a
coastline or you live somewhere
where you've never even seen
the ocean to begin with.